my guest this week is Ali Rizvi Ali
writes for The Huffington Post and his
first book the Atheist Muslim losing my
religion but not my identity is being
published in 2016 he's a strong advocate
for the advancement of secularism and
science particularly in the Muslim world
Ali welcome to the show Dave glad to be
on so we've been doing this as I start
almost all my shows by saying that I
guess we've been doing this on Twitter
for a while and you are another one of
these anti regressive warriors so I'm
happy that you're joining me this week
yeah you can you can't help but be I
mean it's just doing anything like this
it's almost synonymous yeah it
absolutely is so all right we're gonna
we're gonna talk a little bit about the
regressives of course but let's let's
talk about you first I want people to
understand sort of who you are where you
come from you spent most of your youth
up until your early teens in Saudi
Arabia is that right right I did so I
pretty much grew up there I was born in
Pakistan then after that we moved to
Tripoli in Libya lived there for several
years and then I went to Saudi Arabia
where I was actually until high school
and then after that I went back to
Pakistan again for university and then I
came to Canada yeah
why were you bouncing around so much my
parents are professors then they liked
going in different places and they they
you know they got really good job offers
or bulk very very confident and so
they've traveled all over the place yeah
I mean those are just the countries we
lived in and I used to visit all over
the place so just generally when it
comes to North Africa and the Middle
East and South Asia seen a lot of places
going on well interestingly all three of
those particularly Pakistan and Libya
are probably extremely different now
than they were when you were there right
and Libya I don't have too many I mean
that when we live there when either that
was a kid so no I do have strong
memories of it but they're probably not
representative at all the way it is
right now no and if Pakistan is also
very different than it used to be and I
haven't been there for a while now I
can't go there right so we'll talk about
why you
go there in a little bit but let's talk
about Saudi Arabia for a bit because
it's such an important player in world
politics and its relationship to the
United States and I feel like people
actually know very little about Saudi
Arabia the nature of our relationship
what was it like growing up there your
parents as professors obviously came
from the I'm assuming that was
middle-class sort of educated middle
class well how did that relate to
religion and secular realism and all
that it was it was it was complicated so
like another way I describe it is that
my own nuclear family like my parents
and my siblings are sort of a liberal
progressive type of Shia Muslim family
and so we had that and then outside that
I was in the private American school the
American International School in Riyadh
the time so the school was you know
obviously was American so he had
American textbooks we've listened to
American music and you know I mean it
wasn't it was an American school that
had people from about 80 different
nationalities there so it was a truly
international school and then the
outside of that stepped out of that it
was you know cover your hair women can't
drive you know five times prayer and if
you're outside during the prayer you
know get caught by one of the Matawa as
they call them which is the religious
police so it was strange so you know all
of these three things but when you know
when you're growing up with something is
a kid that is normal that's what you
think everything's like so I actually
think that it was a good thing to be
exposed to all of those worlds at the
same time so I was you know when for
instance when 9/11 happened I could you
know the Saudis coming in from their
night I remember the mentality that
there was there one one thing I
described in my book is when I was in
fifth grade at the American school we'd
made paper snowflakes out of you know if
me hold up a piece of paper you cut
snowflakes girl and you know we
decorated them with glue and glitter and
our names we were happy I was about ten
years old and you
even though it was an American school
the Saudi Ministry of Education used to
send an inspector once in a while to
make sure everything's okay everything's
going according to the rules and he came
in and he actually cut one of the tips
off of each of snowflakes he was very
angry and cut them off and we asked our
teacher what was going on so I can Oh
what is this and then she told us about
the Star of David and why we can't have
anything that has six points that sort
of symbolizes that and that was our this
is a whole class of ten year olds that
was our introduction at least my
introduction to the Jews Wow right so
and this was just a spot check from an
inspector but there are kids in Saudi
Arabia we'll go to the Saudi schools
they have to stuff in their textbooks
the guy who did that spot check for us
was actually actually writes the
curriculum for the rest of them so when
9/11 happened I saw that kind of culture
those people coming in from there and
then the people in my school like the
Americans they're the ones being
attacked over here it was it was really
strange seeing it because I kind of
grown up with both sides in parallel you
know the all my teachers were American a
lot of my friends were from the US and
Canada on the other hand the country I
was living in was a place while the
hijackers came from